So, moin
Grüß Gott, Chainlord
Ich war heute Morgen schon in Bayern, da passt das ja ganz gut
Ich glaube, da ist das ja noch immer
Eine Standardbegrüßung in Bayern
Wobei die sagen
Ich glaube, die Standardbegrüßung
Schlechthin in Bayern ist Servus
Und Servus kann man
Glaube ich sagen
Zur Begrüßung und zum Tschüss
Zum Verabschieden
Servus, universell
So, und Chat, geh
Was gibt's Neues
Alle schon am Start hier
Habe die Ehre
Das klingt aber
Das klingt irgendwie so, als hätte das mein Opa gesagt
Vom Alter her
Früher
Mein Opa hat eh so komische Wörter
Immer verwendet, die niemand heute benutzt
Mein Opa hat beispielsweise
Auch nicht Besteck gesagt
Sondern Schanzzeug
Ich hab nie
Also ich hab wie ich klein war nicht gecheckt, was der wollte
Bis ich dann irgendwann mal kapiert hab, dass der Besteck
Meint zum Essen
Der hat nicht gesagt Besteck, sondern Schanzzeug
Das Wort gibt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr
Das wurde abgeschafft mittlerweile
Vielleicht ist das noch irgendwas, was aus dem Krieg kommt oder so
Keiner
Echt?
Okay
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Eigentlich sind wir überhaupt nicht dabei
Aber ich mache das jetzt trotzdem mal
Ich mach mal meine VM an
Was ist denn das?
Was ist das?
Warum liegt das hier?
Das ist irgendwas von meinem iPhone
Sollte das hier liegen?
Auf meinem Streaming-Account?
Sollten hier irgendwelche privaten Videos von meinem iPhone auf dem Streaming-Account liegen?
Ich bin mir unschlüssig, warum das hier liegt
Ich trau mich nicht, das Ganze
Ich trau mich nicht, das aufzumachen
Was ist das?
Okay, was ist das?
Ah, Windows-Things
Okay, trau ich mich, das aufzumachen oder nicht?
Das ist nicht das Fahrrad-Video
Das ist das Lauf-Video!
Genau, das Lauf-Video
Jetzt ergibt sich das Lauf-Video!
Gibt das auch Sinn?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, so vom...
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, das ist das Lauf-Video!
Im Winter, ja
Jetzt...
Der Chat weiß besser, was auf meinem Desktop liegt
Das ist...
JLo, das ist kein schlechtes E-Mode
Ich füge das mal hinzu
Nice
Okay, ich muss jetzt hier erstmal den ganzen Krempel aufmachen hier, also...
Stream starten...
Welchen Pace läufst du so?
Also das Schnellste, was ich bisher gelaufen bin aus dem Kopf...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es jetzt exakt auf die Sekunde stimmt, aber relativ sicher schon
Das Schnellste war 5,22 pro Kilometer für exakt 5 Kilometer
Aber das ist eigentlich eher, wenn ich danach deadge sein will
Also in der Regel...
Also ich glaube letzten Sonntag...
Oder das letzte Mal, wo ich gelaufen bin...
Ne...
Ist das nicht das letzte...
Das letzten Sonntag...
Da war ich ziemlich schnell...
So, dass ich easy die komplette Strecke...
Ohne quasi umzukippen, so übertrieben gesagt, packe
Ich kann es dir sagen, und zwar...
Hier Sonntag...
Running...
5,36 pro Kilometer...
Am Sonntag...
Aber auch exakt 5,01 Kilometer, da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr...
Also normaler...
Also was ich ohne Probleme schaffe, ist die komplette Runde...
Die komplette normale Runde sind 6,5 Kilometer...
So mit 6 Minuten...
6 Minuten pro Kilometer, das ist überhaupt kein Problem...
Und...
Das Schnellste, was ich bisher...
Ich glaube...
Das Weiteste war glaube ich 11,2 bisher...
11,2 Kilometer...
Und das war glaube ich 6,15 oder sowas...
Machen wir aber erstmal kurz Package-Updates...
Weil 8 Schlinucks, by the way...
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, was ich für Dinge hier inszeniere...
Ich glaube, ich verwende das Icon-Set gar nicht...
Aber egal...
Updaten...
Was machst du in deinem Beruf?
Du musst mal bei mir auf YouTube gucken...
Da habe ich einige Videos zu dem Thema...
Wobei...
Man muss sagen...
So hundertprozentig aktuell sind die ja auch...
Ich glaube Leute, das ist eine sehr gute Idee...
Wir machen mal ein Update-Video...
Dazu...
Ich glaube, das wäre nicht verkehrt...
Also aktuell kümmere ich mich hauptsächlich um Cloud-Infrastruktur...
Hauptsächlich in der Google Cloud...
Also wenn du was genaues wissen willst, kannst du mich fragen...
Zum Beispiel Terraform...
Ja...
Aber nicht nur...
Irgendeine Mischung aus Terraform, Kubernetes...
Bisschen VMs, Automatisierung...
Interne Tools bastele ich ab und zu ein paar zusammen...
Die uns das Leben leichter machen...
Keinerweise basteln wir sogar im Stream...
Deutsche Bank nutzt auch Google Cloud...
Du wirst ziemlich viele Leute in der Finanzbranche finden...
Die Google Cloud und Azure verwenden...
Und ich kann dir auch sagen, warum...
Das liegt daran, weil AWS...
Keinen Bock hatte...
DSGVO-konform...
Und deutsche Finanzaufsichtsbehörden...
Konform zu sein...
Und deswegen haben die sich alle für Azure und Google Cloud entschieden...
Es ist ziemlich einheitlich in Frankfurt...
Es ist entweder Google Cloud, Azure oder Google und Azure...
Viele machen Google und Azure...
Weil...
Azure halt für Active...
Oh sorry, sorry...
Es heißt ja...
Ich hab...
Ich hab vergessen...
Es heißt ja nicht mehr Active Directory...
Es heißt ja Azure...
Entra oder sowas...
Alter...
Modgis...
Hahahha...
Modgis es wird Zeit zu bannen...
Und ich meine nicht den ChainLore...
Weiß gar nicht, ob Modgis überhaupt am Start sind...
Doch der Max ist am Start, easy...
Hahah...
So haben wir jetzt geupdatet...
War doch ein gutes, äh...
Ich hab's gar nicht so genau gelesen...
Irgendwas mit Promotion oder sowas...
So haben wir jetzt alles geupdatet...
Oh es gibt eine neue Pizza...
Oh fuck!
Jetzt spackt wieder die VM rum!
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Irgendwas habe ich hier kaputt gemacht in meiner VM.
Das ist nur, witzigerweise,
nur wenn ich dieses Jetbrains-Fenster track und droppe,
dann geht es kaputt.
Guck, seht ihr das?
Nur wenn ich das Jetbrains-Fenster track und droppe.
Seriously, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum.
Jetzt muss ich auch noch neu starten wegen dem Scheiß.
Guck mal, es ist voll broken.
Es ist komplett, komplett broken.
Ich vermute, das liegt an irgendeinem komischen
Track-and-Drop-Bug von VMware.
Es ist definitiv irgendwas von VMware.
Ich habe das, ich habe das witzigerweise,
guck mal, jetzt ist es komplett im Arsch.
Ich habe das witzigerweise auch nur auf dem Streaming-Rechner.
Alter, ist ja gut, Mann.
Jetzt ist es komplett dead.
Nur auf dem Streaming-Rechner,
nicht, also nicht auf dem Streaming-Rechner,
den Streaming-Rechner habe ich ja nicht.
Also nur auf dem Streaming-Account,
aber nicht auf meinem normalen.
Mein Account, ganz, ganz weird.
Weird Champ.
Jetzt starten wir neu und es ist schon wieder,
ist immer noch kaputt, guck mal, Leute.
Ist immer noch broken.
Und das auch, weil ich einmal das falsche Fenster
in der VM-Tracker und droppt habe.
Keine Ahnung, was das für ein merkwürdiger Bug ist.
Guck mal hier, es ist wirklich voll,
voll kaputt.
Da müssen wir jetzt, müssen wir jetzt
Prozess-Explorer aufmachen.
Machen wir mal als Admin auf, schade nix.
Wir machen Prozess-Explorer als Admin auf.
Dann zoomen wir vor VMware, schießen vor VMware ab.
Vielleicht hat man auch Glück, man sieht es im Task Manager irgendwo.
Ah hier, ich glaube, es ist immer noch am Laufen, ja.
Vor allem, vielleicht geht es jetzt, vielleicht geht es jetzt ja schon.
Das ist ganz, ganz merkwürdiger Bug.
Jetzt geht es, glaube ich, wieder.
Ja.
Brauchen wir den Prozess-Explorer gar nicht.
Wie heißt diese Applikation?
Das, richtig, ja.
Der Zugucker weiß Bescheid.
Das ist Roffi oder Rofi oder was auch immer genau.
Okay, jetzt muss ich aufpassen.
Fenster nicht track und droppen.
Please starten.
Leute, ich habe mir ein neues Fahrrad gekauft.
Ist auch eines der Gründe, warum ich heute ein paar Sachen einkaufen muss.
Ja, ist gut, Windows, reg dich ab.
Wie der Rose.
Ich habe mir exakt das gleiche Fahrrad wieder gekauft, nur mit einer etwas anderen Schaltung.
Und nicht für, und es hat keine 5K gekostet, das alte Fahrrad.
Das alte Fahrrad hat 3.400 Euro gekostet und jetzt kommt es.
Das neue ist exakt das gleiche, nur, nur 2x11 anstatt 1x11 Schaltung.
Aber auch nur, weil es das einzige war, was es gegeben hat zur Zeit.
Einfach 1.000 Euro günstiger, nur 2.400 Euro.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das so die letzten übrig gebliebenen dieser Art sind.
Was aber gar nicht schlimm ist.
Weil, ich will eh, sag mal, kann ich jetzt die Toolbox mal starten, please?
Ey, es hat keinen Bock.
Das ist jetzt broken.
Das macht jetzt gar nichts mehr.
Jet, Brains oder Tool, Toolbox.
Jetzt ist, Alter, gehst du weg.
Jetzt ist komplett kaputt, jetzt startet das Ding das ganze Teil noch nicht mal mehr.
Guck mal, und, und, und, mein Cursor eiert.
Geil.
Hä?
Habe ich das aus Versehen uninstalled oder was?
Ach nee, das liegt ja hier gar nicht.
Gehen dann die Produkte an sich noch?
Okay, Rider und so funktioniert noch.
Aber warum tut die Jetbrain Toolbox nicht mehr?
Was ist das?
Hier, Jetbrains Toolbox heißt der Kram.
Das ist einfach nicht mehr...
What the fuck?
Hat sich das irgendwie selbst...
Selbst uninstalled oder was?
Aber es muss ja noch da sein, sonst wird es ja nicht hier drin stehen.
Es gibt Sachen, die versteht man nicht hier, die Luxstells.
Jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage.
Eigentlich hatte ich was ganz anderes vor, als meinen Deluxe jetzt zu fixen, aber das können wir jetzt mal schnell machen.
Die Frage ist, was versucht das da überhaupt zu starten?
Wo liegen denn nochmal diese Startlinks da, diese Desktop-Application-Sachen, die man startet?
User Share oder so?
Nee.
Gucken wir mal, Toolbox.
Hier.
Ja.
Ähm...
Was?
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich da überhaupt finde, man.
Hä?
Okay.
Guck mal, Jet...
Jetbrain?
Da gibt es echt nur diese Dinger.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
System D?
What?
Es ist super weird, man.
Fonts?
User Log...
Genau.
User Local Share Applicate...
Nee.
User Local...
Share..
Share Applicate...
Nee, da ist es net.
Aber irgendwo da.
Snapshot von vor ein paar Tagen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Es...
Das kann sich doch jetzt nicht aninstallen.
Was ist das hier überhaupt?
Was habe ich da überhaupt rumliegen auf meinem Rechner?
Er findet irgendwas, was es gar nicht gibt.
Okay, find.
Find.
Da weiß ich wenigstens, was es macht.
Ich kann halt schreiben.
Name Sternchen Toolbox.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ah!
Nein!
Nein, nein, nein!
Das wollte ich gar nicht ausführen.
Alter, das ist so blazingly fast,
dass ich nicht mal abbrechen kann.
Ich wollte das nicht in den Hintergrund machen.
Ich wollte Slash eingeben.
Okay, schon viel besser.
Viel besser, okay.
Was?
Local?
Local share applications.
Ah ja, hier.
Toolbox, da ist der Krempel doch.
Okay.
Okay, was führt denn der aus?
Home Max.
Home Max Local Share Jetbrains Toolbox.
Gibt es das noch?
Okay, das gibt es noch.
Aber das startet nicht mehr.
Das ist broken.
Nice.
Was, Prozent U?
Was war so immer Prozent U, Mann?
Okay.
Format Error.
What?
Ist das vielleicht ein Bash-Skript?
Das ist, Moment.
Das ist, fuck, das ist.
Das ist 0 Byte?
Meine Linux-Kiste hat das Binary gekillt beim Restarten.
Vielleicht soll ich das doch einfach mal neu runterladen.
Es hatte übrigens einen Grund.
Ich weiß nicht mal welcher.
Es hatte einen Grund, warum ich den Kram nicht über den Paketmanager installiert habe.
Das hatte einen Grund.
Ich weiß nicht mal welcher.
Aber es hatte einen Grund.
Deswegen mache ich das jetzt.
Wegen den Lizenzen.
Okay, jetzt funzt es aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder.
Soll ich es jetzt nochmal?
Das Ding killt meine VM.
Wie geht das?
Was ist da kaputt, Alter?
Wie kann das Ding die VM killen?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich habe noch nicht mal das Fenster angeklickt.
Und es killt witzigerweise nicht die VM, sondern VM wird drumherum.
Die VM läuft ja noch weiter.
Ich habe immer noch kein VM.
Ich habe noch kein Update gemacht.
Das stimmt.
Ja, ne.
Ich habe exakt die gleiche VMware-Version auf meinem anderen Rechner.
Warum sage ich immer andere Rechner?
Auf meinem anderen Account.
Und das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Warum ist der Desktop so sauber?
Hier?
Ja.
Warum nicht?
Dafür habe ich 30 Milliarden Tabs auf.
Konnte man sich das hier nicht gescheit auflisten lassen?
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir VMWare abgeschossen in der Hoffnung, dass es...
Okay, es ist broken.
By the way, warum hat VMWare eigentlich hier VMWare Workstation?
Ja, zack.
Also, das hatte ich ja auch noch nicht.
Das ist ja super.
Was kaufen wir heute?
Ja, eigentlich einiges.
Einiges.
Aber irgendwie sidetracked mich meine Linux-Kiste gerade.
Okay, ich restarte nochmal.
Vielleicht geht es jetzt.
Anbauteile für das Fahrrad.
Wir kaufen ein paar kleine Sachen.
Für das Fahrrad, ja.
Ich zeige euch auch gleich erstmal, welches Fahrrad ich überhaupt bestellt habe.
So, darf ich jetzt vielleicht?
Das ist jetzt okay.
Weird Flex.
Wieso?
Was ist Weird Flex?
Dass meine VM abkackt?
Äußerst, äußerst nicer Flex.
Hast du endlich das Geld bekommen?
Nee, immer noch nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Die haben immer noch nicht bezahlt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin ja nicht darauf angewiesen, dass die das bezahlen.
Die Kohle habe ich schon noch, da ich mir auch so ein Fahrrad kaufen kann.
Und jetzt wird es langsam...
Jetzt wird es langsam wieder warm.
Jetzt wird es langsam wieder schönes Wetter.
Was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt das alte starte?
Nee, das alte war ja weg.
By the way, das kommt doch offensichtlich über irgendeinen Installer.
Äh, was zum?
Piss dich, Alter!
Okay, ich habe seriously keine Ahnung, warum meine VM abkackt, wenn ich diesen Kram starte.
Das kann doch nicht sein!
Also, man muss ja dazu...
Es ist...
Also, das...
Das muss irgendeinen Bug in der Grafik aus...
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Nee, nee, nee, wir installieren die VM nicht neu.
Der Witz ist, ich benutze das gleiche Teil, ne?
Mehr oder weniger exakt das gleiche.
Bei mir auf einem anderen Account und das macht überhaupt keine Probleme.
Also, das muss irgendwas hier vielleicht an den Settings sein.
Vielleicht irgendwas an...
Ich habe eine Idee.
Vielleicht, vielleicht irgendwas an den Grafik-Settings von der VM.
Snapshot laden.
Nee.
Das ist ja nur das Binary kaputt.
Das ist der Rest.
Das hatte ich ja vorher auch schon.
Guck mal, vielleicht ist hier irgendwas an der...
Was haben wir denn hier?
Display?
Wir machen jetzt mal Accelerate 3D Graphics aus.
Nur falls es da dran liegt, okay?
Morgen kommt der Art Reinstall Steam.
Nee, da wird nichts reinstalled.
Habe ich überhaupt noch einen Snapshot?
Ich habe gar keinen Snapshot mehr davon.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das an irgendwie der Grafik-Ausgabe liegt.
Okay.
Das startet schon mal.
Firefox.
Sollte hoffentlich auch starten.
Postchamp.
Mein Desktop ist komplett broken gerade.
Mein Desktop ist komplett broken ohne Grafik-Acceleration.
Alter.
Das ist ja die Wayland-Experience.
Aber echt.
Äh, Pcom oder wie heißt das Ding?
Okay, ohne...
Okay, ich sollte vielleicht auch kein Programm starten, was 3D-Grafik-Acceleration-Kram braucht.
Okay, jetzt starten wir nochmal die Toolbox.
Ob die jetzt funktioniert?
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Vielleicht ist das ein Pcom-Bug oder wie?
Oder was ist das?
Könnte das sein?
Weil jetzt funzt alles.
Dass das irgendein Pcom-Bug in Verbund...
In Kombination mit irgendeinem Bug in den VMware-3D-Geschichten ist?
Sehr merkwürdig auf jeden Fall.
Was ist denn, wenn ich es von Hand starte?
Ja, dann geht's wieder nicht.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Oh.
Weird Champ.
Wo ist denn meine Pcom-Config?
Wo ist denn der Kram?
Pcom?
Nee.
Wo liegt denn das Zeug?
Pcom?
Nee.
Ich könnte einfach mal auf GitHub in meine .files gucken.
Da habe ich das doch drin.
Pcom.
Hier ist doch.
Config.
Pcom.
Ist da irgendwas...
Irgendwas...
Aha, Blur.
Blur ist es vielleicht.
Ist da irgendwas anders da?
Fading?
Nee, das ist immer noch genau das Gleiche.
Da habe ich auch sonst nichts dran geändert.
Ist da irgendein Bug drin oder so?
V-Sync-True.
Keg-Weight.
Gut, jetzt haben wir Updates gemacht.
Jetzt können wir das wieder ausschalten.
Und...
Also, da kann ich mir jetzt auch keinen Reim drauf machen, ehrlich gesagt.
So, stellen wir mal hier...
Aber ich meine, ich habe fucking 8...
8...
Warum habe ich 8 GB?
8 GB Grafik-Speicher.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
2 GB reichen.
Auch dicke.
Für was brauche ich 8 GB da drinnen, bitteschön?
Das ist nice, wenn es dir hilft.
So, mal gucken.
Ob es sich jetzt wieder eingekriegt hat, alles.
Ich meine, es sollte ja einfach funktionieren.
Ich lasse jetzt einfach mal die Finger weg.
Ich mache jetzt einfach mal nix.
Quality is destiny.
Genau.
Ich mache jetzt einfach mal nix.
Ich lasse den jetzt einfach starten.
Ich habe kein aller Kritik.
Sucked.
Western-Beste.
Okay.
Hoffen wir einfach mal, das tut jetzt.
Nice.
Soll ich nochmal...
Soll ich das nochmal ausführen und gucken, was jetzt passiert?
Toolbox.
MonkaS!
Ich glaube, jetzt funktioniert es einfach.
Soll ich mich trauen, das Fenster zu tracken und droppen?
Es geht.
Fixed.
Durch was auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, was es war, aber es geht wieder.
Fixed.
Nice.
Okay.
Kleine Einlage zwischendurch.
War so nicht...
Nicht geplant.
Zehn Jahre IT-Erfahrung.
Zehn Jahre plus.
Senior Five-Heads...
Engineer.
C++ instead.
Ich habe heute Morgen ein Video geguckt.
Wurde mir vorgeschlagen auf dem Handy.
Webserver in Assembler programmieren.
Die Skills waren eindeutig notwendig hier.
Ohne hätte ich es nicht lösen können.
Gut.
Linux-Kiste.
Warum habe ich meine Linux-Kiste eigentlich nochmal gestartet, Leute?
Ich wollte Package-Updates machen, gell?
Ich habe aber Package-Updates gemacht.
Package-Updates gemacht.
Toolbox-Package-Updates gemacht.
Korrekt.
Ja.
Der Name war einprägsam.
So hieß der, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, aber so.
So in der Richtung hieß der, ja?
Wurde mir empfohlen.
War aber echt gut gemacht.
Der Typ ist fein.
Feifett.
Wer auch super feifett ist, ist Ben Eater.
Heißt er so?
Der, der...
Ich baue eine Grafikkarte mit...
Auf einem Breadboard und sowas.
Das ist mir schon zu feifett.
Ich meine, der macht das wirklich gut.
Man kann das nachvollziehen.
Aber ich schaffe es keine zwei Stunden am Stück, mich zu konzentrieren darauf.
Das sind teilweise wirklich richtig lange Feifett-High-IQ-Videos.
Okay, so.
Eigentlich brauche ich die Linus-Kiste gar nicht.
Ich lasse sie aber trotzdem mal gestartet.
Stimmt, ich wollte euch...
Jetzt...
Alter, was ist gerade mit meinem Rechner los, Mann?
Das RGB von meiner Tastatur stimmt jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Es ist jetzt wieder das Regenbogen-RGB anstatt das blaue RGB.
Moment.
Okay, jetzt ist es wieder gut.
Unusable.
Ja.
Jetzt ist es wieder gut.
Jetzt hat er sich wieder...
Hat es Logitech wieder gecheckt.
RGB-Tastatur, klar.
RGB-Tastatur.
Was denn sonst?
Obviously.
X-Fadal, danke für den Sub.
Natürlich, natürlich RGB-Tastatur.
Gibt es noch irgendwas anderes heutzutage?
Und wenn ja, warum sollte man das machen?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Nur B-Tastatur?
Okay.
Also nur...
Das ist dann nur blaue, mit blauer LED.
So wie früher die Monitore, die nur grün oder braun sein konnten.
Oder schwarz-weiß teilweise.
Also ich habe meine Tastatur auch auf B.
Meine RGB-Tastatur ist nur auf blau eingestellt.
Das ist eigentlich ganz angenehm.
So ganz leicht, leicht blau.
Dass dann, dass man sieht, welche Buchstaben das sind.
Und den Rest verwende ich davon eigentlich gar nicht großartig.
So.
Also.
Ich muss ein paar Sachen einkaufen.
Random, random Sachen.
Ich dachte mir, das können wir zusammen machen.
Aber ich wollte euch noch zeigen, was ich mir für ein Fahrrad gekauft habe.
Und zwar, ich habe mir von Rose wieder eins gekauft.
Und das ist das, was ich die ganze Zeit hatte.
Beziehungsweise, was heißt hatte.
Immer noch habe.
Ja, das da.
Und guckt euch mal den Preis an.
Das habe ich damals dafür bezahlt.
Und jetzt kommt es.
Wie viel das jetzige gekostet hat.
Jetzt habe ich mir gekauft.
Also, der Grund, warum ich mir ein neues kaufe, ist, weil das alte nicht mehr straßentauglich ist.
Ich hatte das nur ein paar Monate.
Und danach hat mich eine umgefahren mit dem Auto.
Und, nachdem das ein Carbonrahmen ist, weißt du halt nicht, ob der dir nicht auseinander bricht.
So.
Jetzt habe ich das hier.
Jetzt habe ich da...
Nice, Rose.
Excellent.
Gibt es das vielleicht noch im Cache oder so?
Äh.
Gab es nicht mal einen Cache bei Google?
Wo haben die den denn jetzt versteckt?
Gib es mir mal.
Okay.
Nice, Rose.
Excellent.
Ähm.
End of life.
Ja, das ist end of life.
Hier.
Nicht classified.
Blödsinn.
Nichts classified.
Alter, das ist ja mal voll für den Arsch, Mann.
Hier vielleicht?
Ja.
Hier findet man es.
Also.
Guckt mal.
Ähm.
Ich habe das...
Ich habe das heute gekauft.
Ah, das ist nicht mehr verfügbar.
Okay.
Ich habe das heute gekauft in 50 cm.
Das war das letzte verfügbare.
Für...
2000...
Ich bilde mir ein sogar, dass es nur 2499 € waren.
Vielleicht den...
Ne, den grünen gibt es das gar nicht mehr.
2499 €.
Ich habe quasi ungefähr 1000 € weniger bezahlt, wie letztes Jahr.
Und ich habe mehr oder weniger exakt fast das gleiche Fahrrad bekommen.
Der als einziger Unterschied zwischen meinem jetzigen Fahrrad und dem neuen Fahrrad ist...
Also man sieht ja schon, der Unterschied ist wirklich nicht sonderlich groß.
Ja.
Ähm.
Die Schaltung, das ist 1x11 und das ist 2x11.
Und was ich machen werde, das erste was ich mache ist, ich habe noch ein 11...
Ich habe noch ein 11 bis 40 Zähne Kassette.
Und die mache ich da rein.
Das packt nämlich hier hinten die Schaltung.
Dann habe ich, da kann ich noch ein bisschen einfacher in den Berghof fahren.
Und ansonsten, ihr seht, es ist kaum, kaum Unterschied.
Es ist glaube ich ein minimal anderer Sattel.
Was aber kein Ding ist.
Weil ich kann einfach den Sattel tauschen und dann den alten nehmen, an den ich meinen Popo schon gewöhnt habe.
Ansonsten ist es mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Die Bremsen scheinen minimal kleiner zu sein, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Aber das ist jetzt ja kein Ding.
Es hat andere Räder.
Ja und es hat den Rennlenker anstatt den Gravel Lenker.
Also im Prinzip ist es mehr oder weniger das gleiche Fahrrad.
Ja.
Wie groß ich bin? 1,74 m.
Und ich mag...
Also mein Ziel war ja eigentlich...
Ich poste mal einen Link für den Command.
Mein Ziel war ja eigentlich, ich will ein Di2 1x12 haben.
Aber da findest du nichts gescheites.
Da findest du Rennräder mit.
Die mir von der Geometrie zu anstrengend sind.
Ich als Kacknoob.
Und die Gravel Variante von Shimano gibt es noch nicht.
Di2 1x12.
Also die gibt es 1x12.
Aber halt nicht elektronisch.
Also nur mal für alle Noobs wie mich.
Ich hab das nämlich am Anfang auch nicht gecheckt, was da was ist.
Also.
Das hier bezieht sich auf...
Wie viele Zahnräder man vorne hat.
Und wie viele Zahnräder man hinten hat.
Die coolen Leute nennen das da hinten Ritzel oder Kassette.
Und das da vorne sind Kettenblätter.
Irgendwelche Fahrrad-Pfeifherz haben sich das mal so ausgedacht.
Dass das so heißen muss.
So und der Unterschied von 1x12.
Oder von 1x11.
Versus 2x11.
Steht hier zwar nicht, aber ist 2x11.
Hier hast du vorne zwei.
Und dafür hinten.
Nicht ganz so.
So viel Größenunterschiede.
Dafür brauchst du halt vorne noch so einen Umwerfer.
Und eigentlich finde ich 1x12.
Beziehungsweise 1x11 viel cleaner.
Von der Optik her.
Aber ist halt nicht lieferbar.
Was willst du machen?
Dann kannst du langsam anfangen Fahrrad zu fahren.
Draußen.
Nicht nur hier auf meinem Trainer.
Man sieht es ja auch hier.
Hier hast du viel größeres Ritzel hinten als da.
Hier ist es das größte.
Hinten hat 34 Zähne.
Hier hat das größte hinten 42 Zähne.
Und das ist das was damit gemeint ist.
Wenn hier 1x12 oder 1x11 steht.
1x11 oder 2x11.
Vorne zwei.
Hinten elf.
Oder vorne eins.
Oder Vier.
Und die zweite ist die elektronische Variante.
Also schaltest du quasi nicht mehr mechanisch mit irgendwelchen Drähten.
Die da durch laufen.
Und die Schaltung bedienen.
Sondern da ist so ein proprietäres Kommunikationssystem.
Dazwischen.
Zwischen den Schalthebeln und beispielsweise der Schaltung.
Hier hinten.
Und das geschaltet ist natürlich nach wie vor immer noch mechanisch.
Aber es gibt keine Verbindung mehr mit irgendeinem Draht oder so.
Irgendwie mit irgendeinem Draht oder sowas
Oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig nennt
Zwischen dem
Eigentlichen Schalthebel hier vorne
Zwischen der eigentlichen Schaltung
Und hinten dem Schaltwerk
Es gibt ein Kabel, aber
Da ist so ein rein elektronisches
Bus-Communication drüber
Und das schaltet dann hinten, ohne dass das
Irgendwie eingestellt werden muss, gescheit
Wie man das bei mechanischen Schaltungen teilweise machen muss
Ohne schalten halt ein Ticken präziser
Und ein Ticken schneller als rein mechanisch
So, zumindest das ist mein neues Fahrrad
Ich hoffe, das kommt nächste Woche
Oder übernächste Woche
Und ich werde erstmal nichts großartiges
Daran machen, außer hinten
Eine 40 Zähne Kassette reinschrauben
Die habe ich noch hier liegen
Für noch ein bisschen mehr Range
Wenn es berghoch geht
Dann ist gut
Was ich jetzt kaufen muss
Ich muss kaufen heute, ich habe mir eine
Einkaufsliste gemacht
Ne, das sage ich jetzt nicht
Das machen wir einfach gleich
Das Fahrrad muss ich nicht einkaufen
Das habe ich heute schon eingekauft
Welche Anbauteile kaufst du?
Ich werde das nehmen, was ich schon habe
Schüttelt sich da komplett ohne Federung
Nicht komplett durch?
Ne, Federung brauche ich nicht
Keine Federung
Ich fahre jetzt keine Mountainbike-Trails
Oder so
Ich fahre zum größten Teil auf der Straße
Oder halt mal den einen oder anderen
Aber immer noch ganz brauchbaren Feldweg
Also nix, wo
Große Huppel drin sind
Oder
Ja, wobei man sagt, dass man
Sagen muss, der Mainradweg
Ist auch schon ziemlich verwurzelt
Da hubbelt es auch schon ganz schön
Ne, brauchen wir nicht
Brauchen wir nicht
Ich weiß nur, am Anfang ging mir es ultra auf den Popo
Als ich angefangen habe
Hier mit dem hier
Das ging mir extrem auf den Arsch sozusagen
Weil man das
Nicht gewöhnt ist
Da hat mir tagelang der Hintern
Weh getan, aber mittlerweile bin ich dran gewöhnt
Jetzt tut mir der Hintern nicht mehr weh
Ja, ich hoffe
Das wäre auch mit der Federung genauso gewesen
Ach ja
Und eine Sache habe ich auch gemerkt
Da würde vielleicht eine Federung was bringen
Aber
Also das wäre wahrscheinlich auch das einzige
Wenn man vorne seinen Lenker nicht richtig eingestellt hat
Also wenn man
Wenn man den beispielsweise
Zu flach einstellt oder zu hoch einstellt
Sodass man zu einem schrägen Winkel
Zwischen quasi
Wie man hält und Handgelenk hat
Und man dann ordentlich
So ein bisschen
Aufschlägt
Ja, weil irgendwie
Einen Ast unterwegs durchgeht oder sonst was
Dann geht das halt ungefedert
Bäm, voll in die Knochen, in die Ärmel
Das kann man aber dadurch fixen
Indem man
Das einfachste ist, man zieht sich Handschuhe an
Hast du den China-Hackerman-Leak mitbekommen?
Ne
Das einfachste ist, man zieht sich Handschuhe an
Aber noch viel besser ist
Man stellt seinen Lenker gescheit ein
Und hängt nicht mit vollem Gewicht auf dem Lenker vorne
Sondern hat seinen Arsch ein bisschen an den Knochen eingestellt
Sondern hat seinen Arsch ein bisschen an den Sattel gewöhnt
Und sitzt zum größten Teil mit dem Gewicht auf dem Sattel
So wie es eigentlich sein soll
Was man am Anfang nicht macht, weil einem am Anfang der Hintern weh tut
Wenn man solche Sattel nicht gewöhnt ist
Und eins ist mir auch aufgefallen
Umso mehr Übung man hat
Also das heißt
Im Endeffekt
Umso stärker man reintreten kann
Umso mehr
Entlastet das auch die Hände
Weil, ne
Also umso mehr Power in die Pedale gehen
Umso mehr entlastet das auch die Hände
Weil du weniger Druck vorne drauf liegen hast
Weil du die ja in die Pedale drückst
Weiß nicht, ich kann es nicht besser beschreiben
Naja, zumindest
Ich mach wahrscheinlich den alten
Den Sattel von meinem alten Fahrrad
An das neue dran, weil ich an den schon gewöhnt bin
Und ansonsten bleibt das alte Fahrrad
Einfach auf meinem Home Trainer stehen
Auf meinem Smart Trainer
Und gut ist
Also, ja vielleicht
Vielleicht, das Ding ist
Wenn man
Chinese Hacking Tools
Exposed in Giga League
Alter, wie sich das anhört
Das Problem ist
Das weiß ich aber nicht aus erster Hand
Das habe ich nur gelesen, deswegen habe ich das auch nicht gemacht
Es gibt Leute, die kaufen sich ein
Fahrrad, irgendwie sowas hier in der Richtung
Und machen dann so einen Omasattel drauf
So einen schönen, gefederten, gepolsterten
Das ist für die ersten paar Kilometer ganz nice
Danach hast du aber
Das Problem, dass du zu sehr
Auf deinem Speck sitzt
Und nicht so sehr auf deinen Sitzknochen
Und
Dann fängt das an
Sich, wie soll man sagen
Rein zu drücken und
Zu scheuern
Also du hast nach ein paar Kilometern
Mit so einem harten Sattel tatsächlich
Einen besseren Sitz
Als mit einem weichen Sattel
Und einem gefederten Sattel
Weiß ich nicht aus erster Hand
Das habe ich probiert
War aber für mich der Grund mich da durch zu beißen
Und meinen Hintern an einen harten Sattel zu gewöhnen
Was hat das eigentlich
Das alte für eine Ausstattung gehabt
Was für einen Sattel hat denn das hier
Äh
Okay, das ist den, den ich anscheinend gerade habe
Und der neue
Das neue hat einen
Was für einen Sattel
Ausstattung
Sattel
Rose Edition
Bei Sella Italia
Okay, was auch immer
Das hat ein Loch in der Mitte
Das hat aber hier kein Loch in der Mitte, oder?
Hat das ein Loch in der Mitte?
Da friert man ja im Gemächt
Alter
Ich glaube das ist gar nicht so übel
Falls man irgendwie halt Druck so
Zwischen den Beinen hat
Weil es zu sehr
Also
Wenn der neue Sattel mir nichts taugt
Mache ich einfach den alten Sattel wieder dran und gut ist
Ja die haben ja alle Löcher in den Satteln drin
Okay
Naja
Ich werde es
Merken
Ansonsten mache ich den alten wieder dran
Ja genau
Das ist super individuell
Ich dachte am Anfang auch
Der Sattel
Passt überhaupt nicht zu meinem Pobo
Aber das war einfach
Weil mein Hintern nicht dran gewöhnt war
An solche Sättel
Wenn ich jetzt eine Weile gefahren bin
Ist überhaupt kein Problem mehr
Jetzt sitze ich da eigentlich relativ bequem drauf
Mir tut auch der Arsch nicht mehr weh
Genau
So und deswegen muss ich tatsächlich noch ein paar Sachen kaufen
Das erste was ich brauche
Und da bin ich mir echt nicht sicher was ich holen soll
Wobei wir fangen mit etwas anderem an
Ich brauche tatsächlich eine neue Klingel
Für das Fahrrad
Weil die Klingel ist ein bisschen kaputt
Nach dem Unfall
Ich habe so eine ganz billige kleine Klingel
Die ist nämlich schön klein leicht
Und lässt sich
Lässt sich an und ab nehmen
Ich habe so eine kleine Klingel hier
Nennt sich
Triggerbell
Sowas hier
Sowas ganz kleines billiges
Das Problem ist
Hier sieht man das hier ganz gut
Auf der Unterseite der Abstand
Zwischen dem da und dem da
Ist viel größer als da
Weil das halt
Wahrscheinlich beim Unfall draufgefallen ist
Die geht noch
Aber
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher
Ob es die noch lange macht
Also
Das ist eine ganz kleine billige
Klingel
Die finde ich aber nice
Die kannst du überall dran montieren
Also aktuell habe ich sie noch dran
Die ist bei mir quasi vorne
Neben dem Fahrradcomputer in der Mitte
Bim Bim
Mache mit dem Daumen
Aber warum soll ich da irgendwas teureres dran machen
Ich habe die auch dran gelassen
Ja
Ja ja
Ich weiß
Ich wollte tatsächlich einen Termin ausmachen
Bei einem Laden hier in der Ecke
Aber ich war bisher zu faul
Okay
Moin Max was sagst du dazu wenn jemand eine Sicherheitslücke entdeckt
Ein Passwort im Klartext zu einer Datenbank
Der Typ macht sich einen kompletten Dumpf
Von der DB
Und gibt Daten daraus an die Presse weiter
Damit diese mit der Kamera
Bei denen von den Datenbanken
Genau
Und der Typ
von dem Datenleck betroffen. Also es ist
bestimmt nicht erlaubt. Ich bin jetzt kein
Anwalt, das heißt ich kann es euch nicht abschließend sagen,
aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das hier nicht erlaubt ist,
dieser Park. Wahrscheinlich ist der Zugriff da drauf
schon fragwürdig.
Dumpziehen und Daten rausgeben
ist garantiert nicht erlaubt.
Die Frage ist natürlich, ob man
ihn finden wird, beziehungsweise
ob die Presse irgendwas
liegt, wo sie die Daten her hat. Wenn nicht,
dürfte es sehr
schwer sein festzustellen, wer das Ganze
jetzt geleakt hat. Erlaubt ist es
garantiert nicht. Dann gibt dieser
der Firma nur ca. 2 Stunden Zeit bis zur
Veröffentlichung, ohne der Firma zu sagen.
Also
erlaubt
ist es nicht. An dem Modern
Solution Fall war man auch ein bisschen mehr
problematisch. Und die
hatten auch mehr als 2 Stunden Zeit.
Man kann ja da teilweise die
Newsartikel dazu verfolgen.
Es gab
eine sehr weird,
champig geschriebene
quasi Gegendarstellung von Modern
Solution.
Habe ich
gelesen. Und
da hat es ja auch den Eindruck,
das hat irgendwie
einer dort in irgendeinem
Rage-Anfall geschrieben.
Also das ist jetzt nichts, was ich mir von einer
normalen Pressemitteilung da irgendwie
erwarten würde.
Ich finde den Fall bei
Modern Solution tatsächlich recht interessant
aus genau dem Grund,
es ging ja nicht so sehr darum,
quasi
Daten
abzuziehen, um die
dann, wie auch immer, weiterzugeben, zu verkaufen
oder sonst was. Das war ja überhaupt nicht das Ziel.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger zufällig
aufgefallen.
Beim Öffnen
der Applikation, die die ausgeliefert haben
in einem Texteditor, dass da ein Passwort
im Klartext drinne steht.
Also ich finde, das ist ja der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Das ist für mich keinerlei Reverse Engineering.
Wenn ich, selbst wenn ich jetzt in
dem Hexeditor öffnen muss und
dort ASCII Sachen im Klartext
das Passwort finde.
Dann ist das für mich schon mal kein
Umgehen von irgendeinem Schutz.
Das ist schon mal das eine.
Und das andere ist, warum ist die,
das ist eine Sache, die ich nicht verstehe.
Warum ist die Datenbank im Internet?
Das ist an sich schon mal so ein großer
Fail. Was soll das?
Und dann auch noch für jeden Kunden
mit dem gleichen Passwort.
Plus alles in der gleichen,
das ist auf so vielen Ebenen
Fail, da weiß ich auch nicht.
So wirkt das auch. Baumhausstock, danke
für den Sub. So wirkt das Ganze.
Auch ja. Naja.
So. Aber.
Dann machen wir mal weiter.
Also.
Das erste was ich brauche, ich brauche eine neue Klingel
für mein Fahrrad. Also das da.
In den Einkaufswagen. Gib ihm.
Anscheinend ist das mittlerweile
V6. Wie auch immer.
V4, V5, V1, sonst was ausgesehen
haben. Ich weiß es nicht.
Billige kleine Klingel. Da kann man
im Zweifelsfall, wenn die kaputt ist, einfach eine neue kaufen.
Ich finde das, ich finde
das Ding praktisch. So.
Was ich dann noch brauche, und da bin ich mir nicht
sicher, ob es sowas gibt.
Sechs Zylinder
Klingel, ja. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es sowas gibt.
Und zwar, ich habe als Fahrradbeleuchtung
so ein Ding hier.
So.
So ein Teil hier.
Licht, Licht mit
Radar drinne.
Hast du dich aktiv
gegen Canyon entschieden bei dem
Gravel Bike? Ich habe mir alles
angeguckt. Ich habe mir Canyon
angeguckt, Cube angeguckt,
Rose
angeguckt. Was gibt es da sonst noch alles?
Ich habe mir mehr oder weniger alle Hersteller angeguckt.
Ich habe die verglichen. Da gibt es eine ziemlich coole
Seite, wo ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht
mehr weiß, wie die heißt.
Da kann man die Geometrie
vergleichen von allen möglichen
Fahrrädern.
Dankeschön Patrick für den Sub.
Also da kannst du beispielsweise zwei Fahrräder
einstellen mit der gleichen Größe und das macht dann so ein
Overlay von dem Rahmen.
Und dann siehst du beispielsweise
wie stark nach vorne geneigt du
da sitzt, wie viel Abstand ist
an welcher Stelle
und wie ist das von der
Sitz-, von der Sattelposition
zum Lenker runter. Und da muss ich sagen,
erst danach habe ich mir
damals überlegt
mir das Rose Bike zu kaufen
und ich finde die Sitzposition
halt extrem angenehm,
weil die zwar etwas sportlicher
ist als bei einem
Oma-Fahrrad, aber nicht so
super sportlich,
wie beispielsweise
bei
einem Straßenrennrad.
Und ja, du hast bei den anderen Herstellern
auch
nicht ganz so krasse Positionen,
aber die sind oftmals doch eine ganze Ecke
sportlicher als das bei Rose.
Und ich finde das sehr nice für mich.
Zumal ich
jetzt schon eins hatte ein paar Monate lang
und ich
damit super klar gekommen bin, deswegen will ich
einfach nur das gleiche nochmal haben.
Und ich hätte das gleiche auch immer noch,
wenn mich das Auto nicht umgefahren hätte.
Ja.
So wirkt das, so wirkte
das auch auf mich, ja.
Also ich hab das,
da gibt es ne coole
Seite, Geometrieverkla-
Äh. Ja, genau.
Das meine ich.
Und da kannst du jetzt verschiedene
Fahrräder einstellen.
Musst ja noch die Größe auswählen sowas.
Kannst verschiedene Fahrräder einstellen
und man sieht, dass sich am Rahmen nichts geändert hat,
weil es exakt gleich groß ist.
Aber du kannst jetzt nochmal von anderes nehmen.
Beispielsweise irgendwie,
wie heißt das von Canyon, Grizzly
oder sowas, gell? Oder so
Grizzly?
Ne, wie heißt das, Grizzle? Grizzle?
Oder so? Irgendwie ähnlich.
Grail gibt's?
Grizzle, Grizzle heißt
Grizzle, alles klar, ja.
Ja, kannst
du einstellen, sagst du Größe,
ich muss mal gucken, was halt das ist.
Ah.
Irgendwie sowas. Und dann sieht man schon,
dass es halt ein gewisser
Geometrieunterschied zwischen den,
ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel unterschiedlich,
aber dem sitzt du halt ein bisschen
bisschen
sportlicher.
Minimal. Guck.
Minimal höher und minimal, also
du sitzt allein schon dadurch sportlicher, dass dein Sattel
einen Ticken höher ist und
der Lenker von einen Ticken weiter unten ist.
Ja. Also die Seite ist
sehr nice, wenn man Fahrräder vergleichen
will. Und wo man auch drauf
achten sollte ist,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie der Abstand heißt,
dass wenn man absteigt vom
Fahrrad mit einem Bein links und mit einem
Bein rechts,
dass man nicht die Stange ins Gemächt
kriegt. Also man sollte, wenn man
absteigt, noch hier
stehen können, wenn man, wenn
sein Ding hier ist,
dann sollte das nicht
quasi da sein wollen,
ja.
Da muss man auch ein bisschen drauf gucken, weil man kann's
nicht immer bestimmen, wie man absteigt.
Manchmal musst du einfach schnell
runterspringen irgendwie und kriegst es nicht anders dahin.
Und dann ist es halt blöd, wenn man die Stange
im Sack hängen hat.
Also die Seite ist sehr nice.
Zumindest, ich hab mir so ein Teil
hier gekauft, das ist
ein Licht
inklusive Radar.
Dachte ich mir, coole Sache.
Ihr wisst, ich lass mich von so technischen Spielereien
immer gerne verführen, sie zu
kaufen. Dachte ich mir, mega nice,
ein quasi Radar,
was mir ansagt, wenn Autos von hinten
kommen, plus ein Licht. Rücklicht
brauchst du eh, Licht vorne brauchst
du auch, keine Cloud-Anbindung, aber
glücklicherweise kannst du Licht vorne, so kannst du alles dran machen.
Ich habe es einmal benutzt
und danach nie wieder.
Also ich hab's dran, nach wie vor,
an meinem Fahrrad,
aber
ich hab die, die Radar,
den Radar-Part nicht mehr benutzt.
Weil, es hat laufend
irgendwas gemeldet.
Laufend.
Ich bin die Straße lang gefahren
und es hat parkende Autos neben
mir gemeldet, als dass die von hinten kommen.
Es hat wirklich im
10-15 Sekunden-Takt
hat dumme Geräusche
gemacht, das ging mir so auf den Sack,
dass ich irgendwie nach, keine Ahnung, einem halben Kilometer
abgestiegen bin, nach der
ich meine, ich muss ja erstmal aus dem Dorf hier raus
und dann habe ich
das einfach abgeschaltet
und seitdem nie wieder verwendet.
So, und ich glaube,
das liegt daran, weil ich es nicht richtig
montiert hab.
Ich hab das hinten an der
Sattelstütze montiert, so wie man das macht,
da ist hier so ein Ring dabei, da hängt
man das hinten ran. Ich glaube,
das liegt daran, weil es bei mir ein bisschen zu tief
ist. Also,
guck mal.
Ich hab ja die 50er,
die 50er, 50-Zentimeter-Variante
vom Rahmen
und ich hab den Sattel auch
bei weitem nicht komplett
bis oben hin, so.
Ich hab das halt so eingestellt, so Pi mal Daumen, dass das
ganz gut passt und
bei mir ist es jetzt halt so,
das hängt schon ein bisschen über dem
Rad, aber halt nicht viel.
Ich glaube, also
von der Höhe her
würde ich fast sagen,
hängt mein Radar-Ding
ungefähr so hier, in der Höhe.
Also jetzt nicht an dem Sattel, weil mein Sattel ist
nicht so weit, nicht so weit draußen,
nicht ganz so weit wie auf dem Bild.
So, und ich glaube,
das ist einfach ein Ticken,
ich glaube, es ist einfach nur ein Tick zu
niedrig,
das Teil an meiner, an meiner,
an meiner,
wie heißt das,
an der Sattelstütze.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur zu niedrig
und das hat damit Probleme,
weil das Rad irgendwie im Weg ist.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, gibt es nicht
irgendeinen Halter
für den
Sattel,
dass man das hinten an den Sattel macht,
weil wenn man das Ding hier hinten
hin machen könnte,
wenn man das hier dran machen könnte, dann wäre alles gut.
Dann wäre das hoch genug
und wird
wunderbar funktionieren. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, gibt es da
vielleicht irgendwie sowas, Sattelhalterung dafür?
Ja, sowas hier!
Sowas, sowas, genau sowas im Prinzip.
Naja,
am liebsten wäre es mir eigentlich dahin,
vielleicht kann man das auch 3D drucken oder sowas.
Ja, das ist die normale Halterung hier,
die dabei ist.
Wofür ist das Teil?
Das ist ein Licht,
also ein Rücklicht
mit einem Radar eingebaut.
Das sieht folgendermaßen aus, ich zeige euch mal
das Video dazu.
Mit dem Raspberry Pi eine Rückfahrtkamera
basteln für deine Uhr.
Du kannst das mit der Kamera schon mal nicht und
auf die Uhr gucken kannst du auch nicht, weil du die Hände am Lenker hast.
Höchstens auf das Garmin
oder auf das Smartphone,
aber das funktioniert auch alles nicht.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen,
ich hoffe,
da zeigt das irgendwo.
Also du hast einmal ein ganz normales
Rücklicht,
was bei dem Garmin-Shit ganz gut ist,
du kannst das alles miteinander koppeln, also ich kann von meinem
Garmin-Fahrradcomputer das Licht ein- und ausschalten
und so was.
Zeigt er das heute auch nochmal irgendwo?
Ja?
Genau, hier siehst du es, so sieht das aus.
Also, hier hast du
den Fahrradcomputer und wenn jetzt
ein Auto von hinten kommt, dann siehst du das
so.
Guck, dann macht es piep piep piep piep.
Guck, und dann siehst du hier
auch auf welcher Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite wird dann
eine Leiste eingeblendet, ganz
oben ist ein Punkt, das sind wir
selbst, ganz unten ist auch ein Punkt,
das ist das Fahrzeug, was sich nähert.
Du siehst quasi, dass von hinten gerade ein Auto kommt.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig
porgers Idee, weil man öfters
auf Straßen fährt, wo Autos von hinten kommen
und gerade wenn es Elektroautos sind, so was,
du hörst ja auch nicht immer.
Dafür ist das nice,
aber ich vermute, dass es auf meinem Fahrrad
einfach ein bisschen zu tief hängt.
Dadurch, dass ich mit 1,74
nicht der allergrößte bin, nicht den allergrößten Rahmen,
hab und dementsprechend
der Sattel jetzt auch nicht so ultra hoch ist,
ist das glaube ich einfach ein bisschen niedrig.
Okay, du siehst nicht auf welcher Seite.
Ja, ja, stimmt, du siehst nicht.
Das ist immer rechts.
Ab 30 kmh, ja.
Naja.
Du musst erstmal durchschnittlich 30 kmh
mit dem Fahrrad fahren
und dann hast du ja auch noch ein bisschen Gegenwind
und alles, also da hörst du die Autos nicht wirklich richtig gut.
Für die, die Autos fahren,
ja, das mag sein.
So, und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, vielleicht gibt es eine ordentliche
Halterung, damit man das Ding
an den Sattel machen kann.
Aber das ist ja auch, das ist ja auch irgendwie Schrott
hier, oder? Ich mein schon mal
besser als ganz da unten.
Gibt's vielleicht sowas drum?
Ich muss mal gucken, ob es sowas zum 3D-Drucken
gibt.
Thingiverse.
Max Fahrrad. Ist das schon der neue Link?
Ja, schon der neue.
Ich hab vorhin bestellt, es ist noch nicht da.
So.
Ähm.
Bei Thingiverse wollte ich gucken.
Thingiverse.
Was? Moin, ich bin vor kurzem
mit dem Radfahren angefangen. Ja,
es ist nicht so, ich auch, ich auch.
Also, ich mach das jetzt zwar schon ein paar Monate,
aber es ist noch nicht lange her.
Und ich wurde gleich
umgefahren, ein paar Monate, zwei Monate
nachdem ich das Fahrrad hatte.
Nice, gell?
Ja.
Ich bin vor kurzem, ich hab vor kurzem mit dem Fahrrad angefahren.
Altertief zum Gymfit zu werden
und hab regelmäßig Nackenschmerzen, weil die Schultern
hochrutschen, wenn ich
mich nicht alle paar Minuten daran erinnere,
ist das rein angewohnt. Es ist Übungssache
oder Einstellungssache.
Ich denke auch, dass das Fahrrad einfach nicht
richtig eingestellt ist. Also das Beste ist,
du machst wirklich ein Bikefitting bei einem Laden.
Musst du aber nicht unbedingt.
Du kannst, es gibt auch ein paar ganz
gute YouTube-Videos, wie man das grob
einstellt.
Zum Beispiel, dass du erstmal anfängst
auszumessen,
Abstand, Mitte,
Mitte von
der Kurbel quasi zum
Sattel, Sattelmitte
anfangen und sowas. Da gibt's
ein paar ganz gute Videos auf YouTube,
dass du das halbwegs brauchbar
einstellst. Und eine Sache
ist
die Neigung
vom Lenker. Das hab ich am Anfang auch
verkackt. Also, wenn das
Rad hier ausgeliefert wird,
ist die Neigung
von dem Lenker,
einfach viel zu steil gewesen.
Ich mein, hier sieht man's ein
bisschen,
aber nicht wirklich.
Also, wenn ihr hier so quasi virtuell so
einen Faden runterhängen lasst, ist das
ein bisschen zu steil.
Aber bei mir war der Lenker quasi
noch schräger
eingestellt. Also,
ja, so war dann quasi, kann man
in Paint Bilder drehen?
Geht das? Rotate?
Kann man in Paint Bilder
rotaten?
Weiß nicht.
Wie rotatet man in Paint Bilder?
Ich weiß.
Aber ich mein, das war noch ein bisschen
höher hier eingestellt.
So, und da hast du das
Problem, also, hatte ich auch das Problem,
ähm, da hatte ich
das Problem, dass
der, also einmal der Winkel
zwischen meinem Handgelenk und dem
Arm viel zu, ja,
viel zu steil war,
dass mir die, dass mir die Ärmel wehgetan haben,
die Hände auch innen an den
Auflageflächen wehgetan haben,
und dass ich viel zu
gebückt auf dem ganzen Fahrrad gesessen
hab. So buckelmäßig
gebückt drauf gesessen. Bisschen so, wie du das auch machst.
Und wenn du dann nach, nach, nach vorne
nach oben gucken willst, dann tut dir der Nacken
weh.
Ich glaube, du musst das Fahrrad einfach richtig einstellen.
Ansonsten ist einiges
auch Gewöhnungssache. Gerade, dass dir der Popo nicht
mehr weh tut,
von dem harten Sattel,
und umso mehr du rein
treten kannst in die Pedale,
umso mehr wird auch dein Rücken
und äh, deine
Ärmel und alles entlastet so.
Weil umso, umso mehr Gewicht hast du quasi nicht
vorne auf dem Lenker, sondern
packst du als Power in die Pedale rein.
Ja, Hose
muss sein, ordentliche Hose muss sein.
Also man sollte nicht auf die Idee
kommen, da mit ner Jogginghose zu fahren
oder so. Also ne gute Hose mit
Polster drin macht sehr viel aus.
Also was, was ich
nice finde, ist
Moment, ich sag's euch.
Ich hab nämlich auch ein paar durchprobiert.
Ich hab auch ein paar zurückgeschickt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie nice das Amazon findet,
wenn man durchgeschwitzte Fahrradhosen
zurückschickt, aber
sie haben's nicht bemängelt.
Weil die überhaupt nicht
gepasst haben.
Ich glaube, die hier sind das.
Unschlüssig.
Sag mal Fahrradhose.
Hm.
Das ist...
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung, Leute.
Ich find's in meiner Amazon-Bestellung
nicht. Ich hab nämlich ein paar
durchprobiert und
ich bin auch mit
einigen überhaupt nicht klargekommen.
Die da, hä? Das könnte...
Ja, ja, die sind's.
Die ist das, glaube ich.
Ne.
Ach, scheiß drauf, ich find's jetzt nicht.
Man braucht zumindest...
eine mit Polster drin.
Also, man braucht eine Bip-Shorts.
Oder ein...
Fahrradhose
Bip.
Oder Bip. Weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das schreibt.
Ja, sowas. Sowas hier.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Man braucht auf jeden Fall was mit...
mit Polster drin.
Und dann muss... Da gibt's dann oftmals auch noch
unterschiedliche Polster. Die sind dann
unterschiedlich dick, unterschiedlich lang.
Da muss man gucken, was für seinen
Poppes am besten ist.
Ah, die sind unterschiedlich dick.
Unterschiedlich geformt, die Polster.
Da muss man sich gucken, was für
seinen Hintern am besten ist.
Und das sind...
Also, das macht einen Riesenunterschied, ob man so
eine gepolsterte Hose hat oder nicht.
Ja, die Hose hat
einen Polster am Poppes.
So, ähm, genau. Ich wollte gucken,
ob's eine Halterung dafür gibt.
Bei Thingiverse. Vielleicht kann man
sich das selbst ausdrucken.
Ja! Ja! Alter!
Perfekt!
3D-Druck-Pock!
Genau sowas
brauch ich!
So, und wie fund's das
jetzt? Äh...
What?
Ja, genau sowas! Ja, das ist mega!
Das ist richtig nice!
Kann ich mal das selbst 3D drucken?
Oder braucht man
da irgendein besonderes...
Nö, das ist ganz normal. Ganz normal
3D gedruckt. Dann machst du ein paar
Inserts rein für die Schrauben. Ne, noch nicht mal.
Einfach so durch.
Genau sowas brauch ich, ja.
Ich glaub, ich 3D-drucke mir das selbst.
Ich kauf da gar nix.
Meinst du, 3D-Druck hält das Fahrradgeruckel aus?
Ja!
Hundertprozentig!
No Kappa!
3D gedrucktes Zeug ist so
unglaublich stabil,
das glaubt man gar nicht!
Du musst halt ordentliches
äh...
Filling machen lassen, ja.
Also nicht nur die Wände drucken, sondern auch
ein bisschen innen drin auch.
Das ist wirklich super stabil!
Über, genau, über Licht würde ich mir dann
schon fast eher Gedanken machen bei dem Standard.
Aber was ist denn...
Das Standard-Material für einen 3D-Drucker ist
welches ist da immer dabei?
PPTG oder irgendwie so?
Ich hab...
PLA!
Ja...
Das ist super stabil!
Da gibt's...
Gibt's ein Video, wo einer
auf YouTube sich
so...
Es gibt doch für die Tür...
Es gibt doch für die Tür so Pull-Up
Griffe.
Kennt ihr das?
Die kann man an den Türrahmen
klemmen und dann kann man sich
so hochziehen.
Also, ich hab sowas nicht,
aber man kann sich das...
Griffe, die kann man an den Türrahmen machen und sich dann hochziehen
da dran. Gibt's nen Typ, der hat sich das 3D
gedruckt und hat das ausprobiert, was man da alles
dranhängen kann.
Und hat es nicht kaputt gekriegt.
Also, er alleine dranhängen hat nicht gereicht.
Man kann sich hochziehen,
wenn man kann.
Also, das ist...
Also, 3D gedrucktes Material ist super stabil.
Ja.
Sowas hier. Ich glaub, ich 3D druck mir das.
Das ist natürlich auch geil.
Wenn man so ne Tasche dran hat,
kann man das mal hinten dran pappen und so.
Also, ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich glaub,
ich werd mir das 3D drucken.
Und nichts Fertiges
kaufen.
Mal gucken, ob's bei Amazon irgendwas gibt.
Ich 3D druck mir das selbst.
Du hast 5 3D Drucker.
Brauchst du die auch
beruflich für euren Microcontroller-Kram
oder einfach nur just for fun?
Was für nen Drucker hab ich?
Ich hab ein
i3 Mega S.
Der ist jetzt auch schon 3 Jahre oder so alt.
Ja.
So einen hab ich.
Aber für mein ab und zu
alle Schaltjahre gefühlt mal was drucken.
Gut der.
Mittlerweile gibt's viel bessere.
Für auch gutes
Geld, ja. Also für
günstige Einzugspreise.
Beispielsweise hat der kein automatisches Leveling mehr.
Oder was heißt mehr?
Der hatte noch nie automatisches Leveling.
Neuere 3D Drucker
haben das. Auch
im günstigeren Segment.
Ich muss bei mir noch beispielsweise
die Platte hier unten mit so komischen
Stellschrauben einstellen.
Dass die genau gerade ist.
Also da gibt's auch nix.
Ich 3D druck mir das, Leute.
Okay, siehste mal. Und das ist halt
Das wäre nice, aber das ist halt
angeblich
ziemlicher Müll, wenn man sich die Bewertung
anguckt.
Abgebrochen. Bei der Montage ist der Halter
abgebrochen. Glücklicherweise nicht bei der Verhandlung.
Nicht empfehlenswert. Nicht empfehlenswert.
Also Schrott kann ich mir auch 3D drucken.
Warum ist das Teil so groß?
Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht. Ja.
Gut, dass du es irgendwie am Sattel hier oben
reinklemmen kannst. Aber, sag mal so.
Billige Qualität kann ich mir auch selbst
3D drucken. Dann muss ich bei Amazon nix kaufen.
Sowas ist schon besser.
Moment, es gibt
was offizielles von Garmin
dafür. Da würde ich jetzt
tatsächlich erwarten, dass das sogar
dann qualitativ
kann. Alter,
53 Euro? Sind die noch
ganz bei Trost, Alter?
53 Euro für ein
bisschen Plastik und drei
Schrauben.
Ich 3D drucke mir das selbst.
Richtig hängen geblieben, Alter.
Was ist an der Halterung so besonders?
Die normale Halterung ist nicht am
Sattel, sondern an der Stange.
An der Stütze hier unten.
Und das ist bei mir halt ein bisschen
tief.
Ich finde das hier
eigentlich ganz nice.
Aber Leute, Mann.
53 Euro für so eine
fucking Halterung, das ist doch echt nicht normal.
Ich packe das mal in den Warenkorb,
dass ich nicht vergesse, aber ich kaufe mir das nicht.
Jaja, ich kaufe natürlich noch eine Versicherung
dabei, logisch, alles klar.
Amazon.
53 Euro für ein bisschen Plastik und drei Schrauben.
Achso, ja.
Ja, das lohnt sich.
Weil bei mir scheint es ja nicht richtig zu funktionieren,
wenn es an der Sattelstütze ist.
So, das mal weg.
Ich werde echt sowas hier mal ausprobieren.
Ich mache sowas selbst.
Wie funktioniert denn das, was der Typ hier designt hat?
Weil die Schienen sind ja
unten wahrscheinlich sogar standardisiert.
Das geht...
Ah, okay. Das geht über die Schienen
und dann wird das dazwischen festgeklemmt.
Hier wird es festgeschraubt wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Das geht in die Schienen, dann kommt das rein.
Also ich glaube, ohne Scheiß, ich glaube,
ich druck mir das selbst aus.
Das ist noch super advanced mit der Satteltasche drunter.
Oh, das sieht
ja fast noch besser aus.
Wie hat er denn das gemacht?
Hat er Löcher, hat er in seinen Sattel
Schrauben gebohrt, oder?
Oder hat er Sattelschrauben
an der Stelle?
Hat mein Sattel an der Stelle Schrauben?
Sekunde. Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Keine Schrauben.
Ja, ich habe da keine Schrauben
an meinem Sattel.
Ich glaube, ich druck mir dieses generic
Teil von dem Typ.
Das da.
Das da und probiere das mal aus.
Wie gut das funktioniert.
Ja, nice.
So, next.
Du kannst ja auch Dinge auf eine Liste setzen.
Ne, nur wenn du eingeloggt bist.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt. Ich will mich auch nicht einloggen.
Ach, heute wohne ich mal in 6, 3, 4,
5, 2. Aha.
Okay.
Ich finde das geil, wie das immer wieder
geraten wird von Amazon und Google.
Leaked, Leute. Leaked.
Massive Leaked.
Dann ist beim Unfall meine GoPro Halterung
kaputt gegangen.
Die wackelt.
Dann brauche ich auch eine neue.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, Max, was willst du mit
einer GoPro auf deinem Fahrrad?
Ich nehme die Sachen ganz gerne auf.
Ich zeige die euch nicht.
Aber manchmal, wenn ich rumfahre,
nehme ich ganz gerne mal zwischendurch was auf.
Einfach nur für mich.
Vielleicht mache ich das irgendwann mal
in einem Video als Hintergrund oder so.
Aber dafür ist es nicht.
Und ey, man muss sagen,
die Stabilisierung ist wirklich mega nice.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, habe ich
die Videos hier irgendwie noch?
Die habe ich nicht mehr.
Als Dashcam.
Wer vielleicht jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet
nicht so verkehrt.
Ich habe die nicht mehr.
Die Stabilisierung ist wirklich mega nice.
Hast du deinen Unfall auf Video?
Nein. Da hatte ich sie nicht an.
Zumindest, ich habe eine GoPro Halterung gehabt
von...
Warte mal, ich habe die ja noch hier.
Car Edge.
GoPro Halterung.
What the fuck?
Warum ist der Scheiß so teuer auf einmal alles?
Ein bisschen Metall
63 Euro. Sag mal, haben die
alle den Arsch offen gerade oder was?
Die sind doch nicht mal normal
63 Euro.
Was ist denn gerade los?
Ja, aber das ist das Ding.
Vielleicht kriege ich das
alte nochmal repariert.
Ja, und ich benutze das
nicht so, wie man das hier
sieht, sondern
ich habe das
umgedreht am Lenker.
Also ich habe das...
Guck mal, wenn man hier von oben den Lenker sieht,
ich habe das hier unten bei mir.
Ich habe die Kamera so
eingestellt, dass man den Lenker noch mit
sieht. Für das
angenehmer zu gucken.
Aber das ist doch... Wollen wir mich doch verarschen
oder was, Alter?
Ich lege das jetzt mal in den Warenkorb,
dass ich nicht vergesse.
Fucking Shit, Mann. 62 Euro.
Sind die noch ganz bei Trost, ey.
Für so ein bisschen Metall.
Krasser Scheiße.
Schau auf Ebay Kleinanzeigen.
Was? Letzter Preis.
Oh Mann. So.
Dann brauche ich noch was Neues. Dann brauche ich noch
ein SPC Plus
Stem Mount
für mein Fahrrad. So ein Teil.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem?
Ach, das ist nur der... Moment.
Mit Schrauben. Ohne...
So was hier.
Drück dir doch eine GoPro-Halterung.
Ah. Die musste...
In dem Fall ist 3D-Drucken
nicht so nice. Weil...
Die GoPro wiegt da schon ein bisschen was.
Und du musstest schon wirklich sehr
feste drehen
mit... Anziehen mit der Schraube,
dass die GoPro halt eben schön fest ist.
Ich glaube, da ist 3D-gedruckte Teile
nicht so nice.
Wann kommt die CNC-Fräse zum 3D-Drucker?
Gar nicht.
Da musst du fragen, wann kommt der Laser?
Wann kommt der Laserschneider? Auch nicht.
Ja.
So ein Teil brauche ich noch für das Smartphone.
Das macht man...
Man macht hier vorne...
Ich weiß nicht, ob die überhaupt ein Bild davon haben.
Ja, hier. Hier.
Hier oben...
Wer sieht meinen richtig?
Das hier oben macht man raus und macht das dafür rein.
Und da kann man, wenn man ein Handy
hat, wenn man ein Handy hat mit der passenden Hülle...
Mein Handy hat so eine...
Eine Hülle mit so einem passenden...
passenden Mount. Da kann man sein Handy vorne
auf den Lenker drauf klipsen.
Nicht auf den Lenker, auf den...
Ja.
Wie auch immer das heißt hier.
Gabelverbindungsstück.
Kann man hier drauf klipsen.
Und relativ easy ab-
und wieder dran machen. Das brauche ich. Das ist nice.
Ja.
Weil manchmal, muss ich ehrlich gesagt
gestehen,
ist die Navigation von meinem Gabel
ein ziemlicher Schrott.
Wenn man in einem Gebiet fährt,
wo man ein bisschen genauer gucken muss
und es nicht einfach nur ein Fahrradweg geradeaus ist
oder so, ist die Navigation auf dem Handy
um Längen besser als auf dem Garmin.
Einfach weil halt nicht alle
irgendwie 3 Sekunden
mal ein neues Bild geupdatet wird und sowas.
Sondern halt,
das auch dynamisch ranzoomt und alles.
Garmin... Die Karte
auf dem Garmin ist nice, wenn man die Strecke im Vorfeld
geplant hat und eigentlich mehr oder weniger
nur geradeaus fahren muss.
Oder ab und zu mal ein bisschen abbiegen. Das ist kein Ding.
Aber wenn du beispielsweise
die letzten paar
2-3 Kilometer
irgendwo hin willst und musst dann durch den Ort fahren
und sowas, da ist die Navigation vom Garmin
richtig lahm und kacke.
Da habe ich lieber das Smartphone vor mir
und kann da drauf gucken und sehe direkt
okay, passt, zoomt rein, zoomt raus.
Also eben
so eine Smartphone-Halterung prinzipiell ganz praktisch.
So.
Hätten wir das auch. Was brauche ich als nächstes noch?
Ich brauche USB-Sticks.
Passt jetzt zwar nicht wirklich rein, aber
kennt ihr das Problem?
Ihr kauft euch immer USB-Sticks
und nach 2-3 Jahren
habt ihr gefühlt wieder keine
USB-Sticks mehr.
USB-Sticks lösen sich irgendwie
in Luft auf.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die alle sind.
Man hat nie
USB-Sticks, wenn man USB-Sticks braucht.
Ich habe jetzt noch, also ich hatte mal
einen ganzen Schwung bestellt
und ich habe jetzt hier genau einen,
den ich auf Anhieb sehe. Einen.
Und zwar einen
12 GB USB-Stick sogar.
Wahrscheinlich finde ich den deswegen auch,
weil es der teuerste war.
Und den nenne ich noch nicht.
Sonst wo
ist der Rest, Mann?
Wo ist der Rest?
Ich habe total viel immer gekauft.
Ich habe 5 Stück oder so gekauft vor 3-4 Jahren
und sind alle weg. Hier, warte mal, hier ist noch was.
Ne. Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nur noch den einen. Ich weiß nicht, wo der Rest ist.
Wer nutzt noch USB-Sticks?
Äh.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist die Alternative?
Eine externe SSD oder wie?
Ich kaufe hier auch wieder den gleichen USB-Stick.
Ich finde die nice.
Äh. Hier Sandisk. Wie heißen die Dinger?
Ah.
Sandisk.
Die sind so Silber. Ne, ne. Nicht die.
Nicht die. Oh. Die, die.
Die sieht gut aus.
Sind die das? Ja.
Die haben auf der einen Seite USB-
A oder wie das heißt?
Wie heißt der normale
Anschluss? USB-A?
Und auf der anderen Seite haben sie USB-C.
Die sind beidseitig.
Das dumme ist nur, dass die hier
Guck. So kann man es auch reinstecken. Nicht nur in USB-C.
Die werden ultra heiß. Ja.
Die werden warm. Das stimmt.
Aber
ich benutze die Dinger ja nicht irgendwie als
SSD-Ersatz oder so.
So. Lass mal überlegen.
Das ist günstig geworden. Guck mal.
Die sind noch günstiger geworden als auch vor ein paar Jahren.
Es macht ja eigentlich fast keinen Sinn.
Guck mal. Einer kostet 20 Euro.
64 Gig kostet 12 Euro.
Moment. Ein Terabyte gibt es auch noch.
Pff. Okay.
Wollte es mal nicht übertreiben.
Moment. Guck mal. 64. Hm.
Leute. Ich tendiere zu 64 Gig
ehrlich gesagt.
Sagt mir mal ein Anwendungsfall, wofür
ein 64 Gig USB-Stick nicht reicht.
Aber ein 128 schon.
Also. Da können wir uns
die 8 Euro sparen. Dann kaufe ich mir lieber
5 Stück nochmal davon. Oder 4.
Mir geht nicht.
Ventoy mit zu vielen ISOs. Da brauchst du enorm viele
ISOs, dass du 64 Gig vollkriegst.
4K VR-Port.
Und warum willst du den auf
USB-Stick speichern?
Ich glaube, ich kaufe mir davon
4 Stück und gut ist, dann habe ich erstmal wieder welche.
Ja. Nice.
Okay. Muss ich
abhaken. Zack.
USB-Stick abhaken.
Dann brauche ich noch
was anderes.
Wo man merkt, dass ich alt werde.
Leute.
Boomer-Time.
Wehpaar-Pferdesalbe brauche ich.
Das ist so
ab 30.
Da tun einem immer mal
ein paar Sachen weh.
Und
jedes Mal, wenn ich mal in eine Runde
rennen war, creme ich mir
damit auf der einen Seite
das Bein ein und dann ist es viel besser.
Das ist nice,
das Zeug. Das hilft richtig gut.
Wenn ich nach dem Rennen merke, dass
es mir irgendwie im Bein zieht, kommt es
drauf auf die Wade und dann ist es gut.
Dann ist es wieder weg am nächsten Tag.
Man kann Pferdesalbe
übrigens auch für Pferde verwenden.
Warum es Pferdesalbe heißt, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das hilft aber richtig,
richtig gut, das Zeug.
Top, top. Ich bin überrascht.
Top, top.
Top, Top, Top.
Das war es.
Warum sind die eigentlich so teuer bei Amazon?
Das ist
nicht mal Amazon.
Äh, neue kostenlose
Lieferungen.
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes.
Wir sortieren nach
kann ich nicht einfach nur nach Preis sortieren?
Der Homöopathie-Fuchs, alles klar
Weil ansonsten würde ich mir einfach
Hier
Das ist doch besser
3,05 Euro
Lieferung kostet 4 Euro
Da kann ich einfach 4 Stück davon bestellen
Der erste Seller ist immer am günstigsten
Ja, mit Versand, aber wenn ich mehr als
Eins bestelle
Dann machen wir jetzt das hier in den Warenkorb
Und dann
Sagen wir einfach 5 Stück
Achso
Man kriegt nur 4
Okay
Ja, weil dann ist billiger
Alles, exzellent
Die erhöhen dir die Versandkosten
Wirklich, Pisser
So, ich muss mal kurz abhaken
Was ich schon gekauft hab
Oh, dann brauche ich auch wieder
Passt mal auf, Leute
Beste Sache, ich kann es nur wärmstens empfehlen
Interdentalbürsten
In der kleinsten Größe, Leute
Beste
Gibt jemand von euch, der den Kram benutzt?
Beste, wirklich
Poggers
Und
Muss ich nur gucken, dass ich die richtigen finde
Moment, lass mich mal
Gerade bei Amazon gucken, wie der Kram hieß
Weil
Da gibt es auch viel Schrott
Bei dem einen war ein harter Draht drin
Wo ich mir ins Zahnfleisch mitgestochen hab
Alter, Chat, was ist mit euch los?
Ihr seid so abartig
Hier, die habe ich, die fand ich nice
Moment
Interdentalbürsten
Wie heißt das?
C
PS
Und dann die allerkleinsten
0,6 bis 2,2 Millimeter
Das hier ist
Ich glaube, blau waren die kleinsten
0,9 bis 4
Was ist die hier?
0,9 bis 4 Millimeter
0,8, ja
0,6, ja
Die hier
Die sind nice
Die sind schön weich
Zahnarzt sagt, die sind gut
Mein Zahnarzt sagt nicht, welche gut sind
Mein Zahnarzt sagt bloß, die Dinger sind gut
Aber die sind richtig nice
Also
Ich hatte vor einer ganzen Weile mal
Oben, ganz hinten, vorletzter Zahn
Also richtig, wo man richtig kacke hinkommt
Entzündung am Zahnfleisch
Weil man halt so kacke hinkommt
Und ich hab damit wirklich Wochen rumgemacht
Und ich dachte eigentlich ursprünglich
Oben schon
Dass irgendwas
Das ist ein wurzelbehandelter Zahn
Oben links von mir
Ich dachte schon, ich hab irgendwie quasi Entzündung
Dort, wo die Wurzelbehandlung war
Und das wird jetzt ein riesen Akt und so
Mein Zahnarzt hat mich auch beruhigt
Hat gesagt, ja, nee, das sieht auch nicht so aus
Also
Probieren sie doch mal die Dinger
Und ich hab das ausprobiert
Und nach einer Woche oder so
Wurde es
Viel besser
Und seitdem benutze ich die Dinger ab und zu mal
Und ich kann die nur wärmstens empfehlen
Die sind richtig
Pog
Ich mach damit auch nicht jeden Tag, jeden Zahn
Aber gerade da oben, wo man so scheiße hinkommt
In den Zwischenräumen ist das richtig nice
So
Nee, Zungenbürste hab ich noch nicht probiert
Wüsste ich auch nicht, warum ich meine Zunge bürsten sollte
Warum bürstet man seine Zunge?
Hab ich auch gekauft
Und dann hab ich das auch noch mal
So
Jetzt noch ein weiteres Ding
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, Chatge
Zungenreinigung beste, aha
Aber warum?
Alles klar, Chat
Welche das waren? Die hier
Da gibt's noch andere
Ich bin bei denen hängen geblieben, weil die schön weich sind
Und man sich nicht damit so leicht ins Zahnfleisch sticht
Größer musst du gucken halt
Passend zu den Durchmessern
Zum Durchmesser der Löcher zwischen den Zähnen
Also nicht den Löchern in den Zähnen
Sondern zwischen den Zähnen
Kuraprox
Also nie was von gehört
Ich hab ein paar ausprobiert
Und die fand ich am angenehmsten
So, was wollte ich jetzt noch holen?
Ja, also noch so ein Ding, wo ich mir nicht sicher bin
Seitdem ich letztes Jahr angefangen hab mit Fahrradfahren
Also eines der ersten Sachen, die mir aufgefallen ist beim Fahrradfahren ist
Fahrradfahren ohne Brille ist nicht möglich, wenn's warm ist
Das fällt einem nicht so auf
Wenn man mit dem Oma-Fahrrad bei 15 kmh rumfährt
Aber sobald man ein bisschen reintritt und ein bisschen schneller ist
Es ist nicht möglich, Fahrrad zu fahren ohne Brille
Das geht nicht
Du hast laufend irgendwelche Mücken, Insekten, Zeug in den Augen, in der Nase, sonst wo
Und hauptsächlich in den Augen
Deswegen hab ich mir letztes Jahr eine Brille gekauft
Die ich eigentlich ganz nice finde
Aber die zwei, also aktuell hab ich
Wie heißt denn dieses Ding? Muss ich mal kurz gucken
Aber zwei Sachen, die mir nicht so gut gefallen
802V
Ja, so ein Teil hab ich mir gekauft
So
Also, was da dran ganz cool ist
Die ist schön klein und leicht
Und sitzt bequem
Lässt sich auch in Helm stecken
Oben
Und die verdunkelt je nach Sonneneinstrahlung sich automatisch
Natürlich nicht schnell
Also es ist nicht so, dass mal kurz die Sonne hell ist
Und nach einer Sekunde hast du schon sofort dunkle Gläser
Aber die passt sich relativ angenehm halbwegs zügig
Dem Umgebungslicht an
Also die wird dann immer dunkler und wird heller
Also das ist quasi so selbst
Glas, was ich quasi selbst
Also das ist quasi so selbst Glas, was ich quasi selbst
Tönt und wieder enttönt
Eigentlich ganz nice
Und auch vom, wie es passt, ganz gut
Und preislich auch echt okay
Es gibt aber
Also es gibt zwei Sachen, die mir nicht so
100%ig dran gefallen und warum ich überlege
Mir nicht vielleicht auch noch eine andere Brille zu kaufen
Das erste ist
Die ist in der Tat etwas klein
Die reicht zwar
Für die Augen aus
Wie das geht, klingt nach
Wie das geht, weiß ich auch nicht
Aber ich kann ja in einem Video zeigen, dass das
Dass das funktioniert
Die zeigen ja, das ist ja alles
Alter, was ist das für ein Schrottvideo, man
Naja, man sieht es ein bisschen vielleicht
Also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht, wie man es
Guckt, die tönt sich
Die tönt sich von selbst
Das ist natürlich, weil es kein gescheites Video zu gibt
Aber das funzt, das funzt
Das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert
Also es gibt aber zwei Sachen, die mir da dran nicht gefallen
Erstens, ist die manchmal bei normalem Licht
Einfach schon
Zu dunkel
Standardmäßig
Das ist das eine
Und auf der anderen Seite
Das dauert manchmal ein bisschen, bis die sich angepasst haben
Aber das Hauptproblem, was ich mit der hab
Die ist mir ein bisschen zu klein
Frontal und so ist alles gut
Aber wenn du deinen Kopf ein bisschen schräg hast
Mal irgendwie guckst
Ich hatte es trotzdem
Dass ich Insekten unter die Brille bekommen habe
So schräg von oben
Hier irgendwie so ein bisschen von oben
Von der Seite, von vorne, von unten
Also alles, was nicht frontal ist
Das sind meine Probleme
Deswegen bin ich am überlegen, ob ich nicht eine andere Brille noch kaufe
Dann wäre natürlich die Frage, welche
Und lohnt sich das
Wenn man schon die hat
Ich weiß es nicht
Also wo ja die ganzen Fahrradpros
Drauf schwören
Das ist
Ähm
Oakley
Oder so
Oder wie heißen die
Oakley, da schwören die ganzen
Leute ja drauf
Das sind so richtig fette Dinger
Sieht wirklich aus wie so eine halbe Skibrille
Die sind natürlich auch relativ teuer
Und da brauchst du dann auch wieder mehrere, je nach Wetter
Ja
Da brauchst du also
Das willst du dann nicht anziehen, wenn schlechtes Wetter ist
Und umgedreht
Das geht halt extrem ins Geld
Deswegen fand ich das andere halt super praktisch
Die kannst du immer anziehen
Bei schönem Wetter und bei schlechtem Wetter
Du hast vier Stück von
Aber auch schon einmal 600 Euro
Versus 59 Euro
Netleader
Welche hast du denn und welche kannst du empfehlen
Ich finde das auch sehr undurchsichtig
Was die
Was die da haben
Die haben ja auch angeblich solche
Pro Gamer Brillen
Also nicht wirklich Pro Gamer Brillen
Aber so ein bisschen das, was sie damals
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese Pro Gamer Brillen
Die so gelb waren
Optic Scope und sowas
Sowas haben die auch
Was die sagen
Dadurch wird die Straße besser sichtbar
So Wellen in der Straße und so
Ich weiß es nicht
Ich mein
Stylish aussehen tun die Dinger ja schon
Irgendwo ja
Ist da ein Telefon vorne drauf gewesen
Warum ist da ein Telefon vorne drauf
Ist das ein Telefon
Ne
Kein Telefon
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Telefon Hörer
Ja und die haben wieder 3000 verschiedene Brillen
Und ich hab keine Ahnung welche davon
Aber stylisch sehen sie aus
Du hast eine was
Ok
Klare
Oh Clay was hast du für eine
Moment wie heißt das
Sutro
Äh
Die Amazon Suche ist Schrott
Keine Ahnung das mach ich heute nicht
Da muss ich mir erstmal ein bisschen genauer
Gedanken zu machen
Was ich mir da hole
Das lass ich erstmal
Ja aber eine Sache
Das brauch ich wirklich
Und zwar
Ich hätte gerne eine super leichte und kleine
Powerbank
Powerbank klein
Und leicht
Guck ob man da irgendwas gescheites findet
Weil
Ich hätte gerne was dabei
Beim Fahrrad fahren
Ich hab aktuell eine dabei
Die ist mir aber zu groß
Mit der ich mal notgedrungen
Wenn es notwendig ist
Oder mein Licht
Was für ein Ding
Anker ah China Chinesen
Anker
Bike24
Ja das ist deutlich sinnvoller
Da hast du recht
Anker Power Core
Mini
Das ist ja rund
Aber sagen wir mal so
Sowas in der Größe vielleicht
Sieht aus wie eine E-Zigarette
Höchstleistung für iPhone
Ich hatte mir mal irgendwann eine rausgesucht
Aus irgendeinem Fahrrad Thread
Auf Reddit
Habe ich das vielleicht noch gespeichert
Als Empfehlung
Keine Ahnung ob das was taugt
Wo habe ich denn das
Sag mal
Ist die Amazon Suche wirklich so beschissen
Wenn man seine eigenen Bestellungen durchsuchen will
Findet man nix
Ach so ab alter bin ich dumm
Ich hab das ja auch noch gar nicht
Ich hab das ja auch noch gar nicht bestellt
Alter
Wenn ich mit Stellung nix finde
Low IQ
Ukraine
China Chinesen
Das ist doch eh alles das gleiche drin
Oder
Lass mich mal kurz gucken
Ich habe mir irgendwo gespeichert
Nightcore
Hat auf Reddit einer empfohlen
Nightcore Power Bank
Und dann welche genau
10.000
So ein Teil
Ok die ist echt klein
Und ich meine die hat Carbon
Rennoptik ansonsten
Klar ja viel schneller
Eine SP Connect Power Bank
Du meinst das man das an so eine Halterung
Anschließt aber warum
Ok die Idee ist cool
Gäbe ich dir recht
Aber ich weiß nicht ob das so sinnig ist
Also
Ich habe eine Tasche bei mir
Unter dem
Ja wer ist denn das
Unter dem Rohr
Hängen vom Fahrrad
Da ist unter anderem dann halt eine Power Bank drinnen
Und dann mach ich ein USB Kabel raus
Und stöpsel das an
Ich glaube nicht das ich wirklich eine SP Connect Power Bank oder sowas brauche
Gutes Review der Nightcore Power Bank
Zeigt das sie nicht gut ist
Sagt warum ist sie nicht gut
Nightcore Power Bank
Ok sie ist nicht gut
Alles klar warum
Ok
C
NB 10.000
Ja
Conclusions
10.000-K Еtrich
cemetery
NB 10.000-K Eright
Very light. So small that it lacks structural integrity.
The power bank, like all the others in this series,
charge a premium for that smaller size and lighter weight class.
The 20k MB20,000 power bank has a 45 watt capability,
but if you use that, you lose a huge amount of the power bank's capacity
and it gets really hot.
That isn't ideal and is the only big negative I found on any of these power banks.
If you only use it at 25 watts, it's actually the most efficient of the bunch.
The Carbo 20k is the world's lightest power bank of this capacity.
No idea if that is true, but it is the lightest one I have seen yet.
Grain of salt with that. Remember, they push...
The definition of 20,000 mAh is by pushing the voltage up.
It is a basic power bank.
So, which power bank do you want?
The Carbo 20k does seem like it has more durability
versus the other 20k.
Let me know if you have or want any of these power banks.
Time to put the stickers on them.
This is almost $300 of power banks.
Expensive video to make.
I wish I didn't make this video and instead had $300 in my pocket.
There will be affiliate links down in the description,
which cost you nothing but help support the channel.
Okay, does...
Und das andere Vergleich hier mit irgendeiner Anker-Powerbank.
Lass uns doch mal gucken, was ist denn hier so der Unterschied dazwischen.
Ja.
Okay, also die Dinger sind ziemlich Schrott.
Okay.
Dann weiß ich immer noch nicht, was ich nehmen soll.
Also hiermit, ich glaube nicht, dass das sinnvoll ist.
So ein SP-Connect-Charging-Teil.
Weiß nicht.
Zumal, das ist ja richtig sinnlos.
Jetzt mal seriously, ja?
Wenn ich das Ding anschließen muss an ein USB-Kabel
und dann mein Handy da drauf mache,
warum kann ich nicht das USB-Kabel auch direkt ans Handy anschließen?
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Wozu brauche ich ein Wireless-Charging-Ding?
Das ist richtig unsinnig.
Ach, das hat einen Akku, das lädt da ein bisschen auf.
Okay, dann ist schon besser.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, Overkill.
Das machen wir nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das machen wir nicht.
Aber wenn es einen Akku hat, dann passt das ja.
Dann ergibt es sogar noch irgendwo Sinn.
Dann kannst du es aufladen, nicht gerade im Fahren schon.
Weil wenn du eh im Fahren erst auflädst,
dann macht es ja keinen Sinn.
Jo.
Brauche ich einen sonst noch?
Weißt du, haben wir ja schon.
Ja, mit dem anderen Kram warte ich...
Warte ich mal, bis das Fahrrad da ist.
Okay, wie viel Amazon-Stells haben wir jetzt?
Wir haben 13 Sachen drin.
Nice.
212 Euro.
Okay, easy.
GG Eats.
Erstmal ordentlich Geld ausgegeben.
Moin.
Ich hoffe, dass das Fahrrad nächste Woche auch ankommt.
Die haben angeblich Lieferzeiten von, ich glaube,
vier bis sechs Werktage.
Sowas.
Ihr habt Glück, ich habe das letzte erwischt.
Bin jetzt nur am überlegen.
Fahr ich erst mal eine Runde?
Und tauscht dann die Kassette aus?
Oder tausche ich gleich die Kassette aus und fahr dann eine Runde?
Ich glaube, ich fahre erst mal eine Runde ordentlich.
Und danach tausche ich die Kassette aus und fahre noch mal eine Runde.
Eine ordentliche Runde.
Tag später.
Jo, alles klar, Leute.
Ich bin fertig einkaufen.
Ich glaube, ich habe alles.
Das haben wir...
Haben wir...
Mit der Fahrradbrille.
Das habe ich erst mal aufgeschoben.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Echt? Wann hast du subscribed?
Ich habe dich gar nicht gesehen.
Aber schön, dass du da bist.
Nice.
Bist du mal komplett untergegangen.
Michael, 50 Milliarden vor 7 Minuten und davor noch der 7 LQRS.
Danke, Leute.
Nicht gesehen.
Baumhausstock hat resubscribed.
Chris hat resubscribed.
Fatal auch am Start.
Leute, ich war zu sehr vertieft in meinen Einkaufsstells.
Massive Subscribers, Leute.
Hast du das SpiegelTV-Video gesehen?
Das SpiegelTV-Video.
SpiegelTV-Video.
Welches?
Das.
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Nee.
Habe ich nicht.
Aber Deutscher kann ein Titel nicht sein, oder?
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Nee, wir schauen das jetzt nicht.
Ich muss jetzt mich ein bisschen ausruhen.
Und heute Abend wird richtig hardcore MMO Kreiselgrind gemacht.
Es gibt nämlich PvP-Event, was es noch nie gegeben hat in dem Game in dieser Form vorher.
Da muss gegrindet werden.
Home-Invasion-Event.
Ja, ich habe halt das High-Performer-Kreiselgrind-Mindset.
Ist nur 12 Minuten?
Okay.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Das da?
Ich lasse das auf.
Morgen früh ist Aufwachen-Stream, Leute.
Da gucken wir uns das an.
Deswegen habe ich so viele Tabs auf, weil ich nie dazu komme, um wirklich alles zu gucken.
Alles klar, Leute.
Pogu.
Dann werde ich mich jetzt mal Richtung MMO Kreiselgrind begeben.
Das bringt dir genau die richtige Aggression für PvP.
Nee.
Aggression im PvP taugt nix.
Da spielt man schlecht.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich eh wieder krass weggezerrt von 200 Gegnern oder so.
So, Archlinux.
Gibt es wieder irgendwelche neuen Packages?
Während wir gestreamt haben, haben wir in den letzten 2 Stunden keine Package-Updates.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Achtsch, by the way.
Leute, wir sehen uns morgen früh wie gehabt.
Gleiche Uhrzeit wie immer.
Wenn ihr in den letzten paar Streams nicht dabei gewesen seid,
die geplante Uhrzeit hat sich ein bisschen nach hinten verschoben.
Früher war ich ja teilweise schon um halb 9, 9 am Start.
Jetzt ist es eher so halb 10.
10 manchmal auch erst.
Das liegt daran, weil ich noch mal eine Runde rennen muss.
Und ich sonntags morgens mich mittlerweile so drauf eingeschossen habe,
meine lange Runde zu rennen,
dass es einfach unter einer Stunde nix wird.
Deswegen erst kurz vor 10 oder um 10 bin ich dann am Start.
Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Es schwankt immer ein bisschen, ja.
So um 10 Uhr rum.
Morgen wieder 11 Kilometer.
Also mein Ziel ist,
sobald es wieder warm wird
und ordentlich schönes Wetter ist,
so wenn es keine Ahnung mal so 16, 17 Grad ist, schönes Wetter,
will ich mal die Runde hier am Main rennen.
Das sind ungefähr
so 10 Kilometer hin und 10 Kilometer zurück.
So insgesamt 20 Kilometer.
Und da muss ich mich schon so ein bisschen drauf vorbereiten jetzt.
Gucken, das wäre dann das längste, was ich geschafft habe bisher.
10 hin, 10 zurück.
Da muss ich dann aber auf jeden Fall was zu trinken mitnehmen.
Ach ja, das ist auch so eine Sache,
das wollte ich tatsächlich bei Amazon auch gucken, fällt mir gerade auf.
Es gibt doch,
ich weiß halt nicht noch, was ich da suchen muss.
Es gibt so Umhänge-Dinger,
wenn man längere Strecken rennt,
da gibt es so Umhänge-Dinger,
wo man sich was zu trinken reinmachen kann
und irgendwie so zwei Riegel oder so reinstecken kann.
Und ich meine keine Gürtel zum Umhängen,
sondern so eine Jacke zum Anziehen,
wo da ein bisschen Platz ist für eine Trinkflasche und
so eine Art Dealertasche, ja.
Nein, keine Bauchtasche, was zum Umziehen.
Bauchtasche kannst du ja keine Trinkflasche reinmachen.
Da rutscht dir ja die Hose, Mann.
So eine Jogger-Weste, genau.
Ja, genau, so was.
Das heißt ja wahrscheinlich nicht so.
So was in der Richtung. Ja, so was.
Genau, so was in dieser Richtung.
So was meine ich, genau.
Was taugt denn da?
Hide, was?
Hidefly.
Ja, obviously.
Warnweste mit Reflektoren.
Ich hätte was, ich hätte gerne was,
ist da ein Licht?
Nee, da ist kein Licht dran.
Das ist einfach nur übertrieben Reflektionsstelz.
Also, Battlefield 3 just got a lot of new players.
Gotted ist das wirklich?
Weil ich muss ein bisschen, so was hier in der Richtung,
ich muss ein bisschen was zu trinken mitnehmen,
wenn ich die größere Runde renne.
Gerade wenn es warm ist.
Ah, da muss ich mal gucken. Weiß auch nicht.
Ey, keine Ahnung, muss ich mal schauen.
Ja, wie ist das denn hier? Steam?
Stats?
Battlefield 3.
Stimmt das denn, was der Luku da schreibt?
Gucken wir mal.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Oh, doch!
Tatsächlich, guck mal da!
Warum spielen denn auf einmal wieder die Leute Battlefield 3?
Was ist denn da los?
Ach, Moment, das war schon am 5. Februar.
Jetzt sind wir wieder unten.
Jetzt sind wir wieder unten da, wo wir vorher schon gewesen sind.
Haben wir verpasst, Leute.
Die letzte Gelegenheit,
Weihnachtsnoobs in Battlefield 3 zu kriegen.
Vorbei.
Vorbei ist es.
Wir haben es verpasst.
Sadge.
So gut.
Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
See you.